lunch morning time
but we also if you can see
right here do you see it right there
do you see the ftx logo wait wait that's
because ftx
is now sponsoring today's episode of
lunch month
then i to sponsor all of them but today
they're going
they're sponsoring today yes
what's better good
and
ftx today just launched
stock trading
with no fees
no trading fees but also no payment for
order flow
so unlike other people who say hey no
fees but we have payment for order flow
these guys no fees no payment for order
flow they also happen to be one of the
largest crypto exchanges in the world
and so there is a massive amount of
liquidity
and generally i tend to think these guys
move fast one thing that people may or
may not have seen is that
recently sam bank midfield had some
comments about bitcoin and bitcoiner
started tweeting at him saying hey what
are you doing what are you doing what
about lightning all stuff jack dorsey
everyone was tweeting at him you know
what he said
integrating the lightning network that
actually sounds pretty interesting
within like 24 to 36 hours brett who's
the president of ftx and elizabeth stark
who runs lightning labs they were on a
call together
trying to figure out how do we get
lightning labs uh or lightning network
uh integrated into ftx
speed and the willingness to go ahead
and always try to be at the forefront of
all this
i like it let's go game on have you
interviewed elizabeth on this podcast uh
i don't think i've ever had elizabeth on
uh but i've had uh
brett from uh ftx so go check out
she might be an interesting candidate
ftx i'm gonna we will have to get that's
a great idea actually all right
let's get into it what do you got for us
okay
the dow jones industrial average posted
its biggest loss since 2020 on wednesday
after another major retailer warned of
rising cost pressures confirming
investors worst fears over rising
inflation and
sell-off the fed's in control if the
federal reserve says that we're going to
pump liquidity into the market we're
going to drop the interest rates game on
people just get long and they say hey
j pal pump my bags oh now
what the fed is saying is we're taking
the party away we're taking that
liquidity out of the market we're gonna
take away that cheap capital we're gonna
jack up interest rates they're talking
about 50 basis point hikes in the next
couple of meetings eek
guess what
watch out below
and here comes the stock
but the thing is with stocks they don't
just fall off a cliff it's not just like
a we're going we're going we're going
like an elevator down no they take the
stairs down they just kind of
you like that you like that analogy yeah
instead of elevator down we go stairs
escalator or you escalated that's fine a
little bit bumpier than uh than an
escalator but you get the point
go ahead i don't know what kind of
escalators you've been on ow every time
all right
so what's up with tesla tesla the snp
500
booted tesla from its esg index as part
of an update to its annual list
meanwhile apple microsoft amazon and
even oil and gas multinational exxon
mobil were still included what do you
think about this well so i'm so confused
because they they they said that um
basically like uh they said that tesla's
lack of a low carbon strategy and codes
of business conduct along with racism
and poor working conditions
affected the score but now
exxon mobil
and
polina let can i just save you some time
what this is absolute [ __ ]
let's just call space no but i'm just
the reason why people come to watch this
show is because we just call it how we
see it i understand this is [ __ ] i'm
just trying to understand their
perspective they have no perspective
this is literally some
like quiet or i'm sorry loud minority
extremists
have taken over
this psg no no the esg movement and
they're yelling and screaming they've
made it about all this nonsense
business codes what are we talking about
what we should be talking about is
people who started the esg movement
whatever that originally was i actually
think that they were good intentioned
they wanted to say hey we should care
about the environment again i don't
think anybody wakes up like we should
destroy the environment today it's all
trade-offs hey we need to do acts what
is going to be the environmental impact
but the people who started this that had
good intentions they said we want people
who are good for the environment yeah
and so guess what
tesla is probably
one of maybe the best single company for
the environment in all of america
they have ushered in electric vehicle
revolution
yeah i think but i think for a long time
esg and like
corporate sustainability it's a religion
it's just i mean it's just kind of like
a buzzword that doesn't actually mean
anything no it is a religion and a cult
at this point and literally if you talk
to these people you're like okay you
believe in esg and then you ask them
like how are what are you doing and like
we bought carbon offsets
like what
i don't know enough to comment but you
go
i i mean i don't really have to say that
elon said it all yesterday he was like
literally these people are psychopaths
and the fact that exxon is considered a
top 10 esg company think about that
exxon mobil is considered a top 10 esg
company in tesla's models
i don't understand that bizarre it's
stupid
and i think what's going to happen here
remember what we talked about all like
the wokeness all that stuff the pendulum
that swung the pendulum swinging back
now
esg
is gonna be a victim of that pendulum
swinging back it's gonna swing back and
just smash through the esg narrative
yeah it's all a mirage it's like the uh
what are they called wizard of oz they
pull back the curtain
like what
he's got wizard of oz but yeah
you wanna know another stat sure i
forget the exact numbers but there was a
study done on a bunch of financial asset
management firms that they all changed
the language on their website to be
where esg friendly where esg conscience
like you know all this nerd stuff yeah
and then like 80 of them didn't change
any of their investments
so that it's all marketing
everything is marketing all of life is
marketing it's [ __ ] it is just
[ __ ] and by the way here's the thing
that gets people real worked up tell me
is that when you start to say it you
know what they start yelling about what
they start literally just uh
pontificating about how you're a bad
person
they don't actually address the issues
it's called straw man
what is it called
straw man not argument but the device
the literary device bitcoin mining is a
perfect example
bitcoin mining is 58.8
renewable energy
58.8
renewable energy okay the united states
economy is 12
so bitcoin mining
is about four times
more sustainable percentage
than the us economy
and rather than say look at bitcoin
mining look at how amazing
this is they have reached almost 60
uh renewable energy consumption mix yeah
instead what we have is the cftc
chairman and a bunch of other people sen
yelling and screaming about how
bitcoin's bad for the environment
you know what's bad for the environment
cleaning your clothes
your refrigerator
christmas lights oh don't come after my
christmas lights that's christmas lights
in america consume more energy than some
countries oh wow
sounds horrible oh my god let's all
cancel christmas now mine are mine are
small
your christmas lights are small yeah i
don't take up that much energy
don't bow to their narrative blatant
don't be coming we have christmas lights
because we like christmas you were
against my christmas not for the energy
consumption i just don't like christmas
lights in october
that's a whole different story christmas
is for december and december only
october no christmas january no
christmas is a december activity straw
man fallacy thank you to the people they
got my baby they got it all right let's
move on to the next thing andreessen
horowitz the venture capital firm is
launching a new vertical fund
exclusively focused on opportunity and
the opportunities in the games industry
it's a 600 million dollar vehicle
dedicated
to
games this is really interesting the
the fund is led by gp's general partners
andrew chen john ly and james gwetzman
uh i think that this is very smart but
andreessen also they create a highlight
video first of all that was pretty dope
oh they created a whole highlight video
they cut up a bunch of stuff it was like
damn am i watching a movie trailer i was
very impressed with the highlight video
uh but the second thing is uh their
whole point was like hey we've been
doing this and they had a whole list of
roadblocks actually infinity like all
these things that they
already invested in in the past
right and so now they have a dedicated
fund for it and what it really does it
just speaks about the vertical um kind
of specialization in venture right is
there's going to be generalist funds and
there's going to be these vertical
specific ones and now they have a
vertical speed yeah no but i think
andreessen has always kind of done
vertical specific ones yes they are a
fundraising machine
yeah 600 million is a lot of million
speaking of not a lot of million
oh damn what a lead what a transition
melvin capital says it's winding down
funds and returning money to investors
during market turmoil remind us anthony
who is melvin capital why do we know
melvin capital
i feel bad for them really yeah i
actually do it's a hedge fund yeah it's
a very large hedge fund uh gabe plotkin
who i don't know um but but seems like a
a good guy who's trying to do the best
that uh that he can out there uh he was
a star trader sac capital he left
started melvin raised a lot of money and
he was short a ton of stocks
or
a decent number of stocks and in some of
those cases they were uh financial
structures that allowed for the mean
stock traders or the reddit uh crowd to
short squeeze him now
i don't feel bad that you got short
squeezed because basically that's how
markets work is you get overextended if
you don't underwrite risk whatever
that's how it works but
what ended up happening is uh they went
from managing a you know 12 billion
hedge fund they lost a bunch of money uh
there was a number of people who came in
i think citadel and uh 0.72 came in gave
a bunch more money uh now they're
basically shutting down they've just
gone on this very bad streak of
investing i think it's two things one is
psychologically like when you start
losing money it's hard to come back
right you basically have the extremes if
you get punched in the face
from an investment standpoint either you
start compounding a lot of bad decisions
because you're taking too much risk to
try to get back or you just get super
focused and you go on a run of a
lifetime right because you're trying to
get back and so in this case uh things
haven't turned around um but that's not
just a melvin capital thing but they
basically had the meme stock thing
happen during a bull market and then
right as they were trying to come back
they got hit with this uh bear market 60
tiger global down you know 45 or so you
see a bunch of these hedge funds all
suffering and so i think that some of it
is just macro environment and then also
uh the issue they got into now the
question to ask is well one of those
things very quickly that people may not
know about hedge funds is that you can
raise money let's say i raise a hundred
dollars and that hundred dollars goes to
200
at the end of the year i take my fees
based on the fact that i doubled the
money now if all of a sudden the value
of the fund goes down over time and now
it's worth 50
i don't get any fees until i get the the
value of the fund back over the 200 mark
it's called a high watermark and uh so
when something draws down a lot so if it
draws down 75 percent your 100 is worth
25 you have to get a 400 increase just
to get back to break even and then
anything past that you get your feet so
what happens a lot of times is the hedge
funds will shut down and return the
capital and then they'll just go raise
another fund because the new capital is
not subject to the old high water mark
so it'll be interesting to see what they
do here they convert it into a family
office do they where they manage their
own money or do they go raise a new fund
with new high water markets interesting
we'll see
yeah um yeah just it just reminded me of
the whole like gamestop situation i mean
it is wild that essentially i mean in a
very basic way
people on reddit in a random forum took
down a hedge fund one time it's not
exactly true but one time directionally
anthony
argued with
i don't want to say a guy's name no i
was at dinner
i was at dinner with my beautiful lovely
intelligent wife here there's a couple
other people at the table one guy was a
really big hedge fun guy uh and it was
right about this uh moment and he
started talking about how uh it should
be illegal that the redditors short
squeeze the hedge fund uh he said
they're manipulating the market and i
was like hitting him under the table
because i knew i knew the guy who's
sitting next to me who's a good friend
of mine he was like
like like call off the dogs don't say
nothing
and i was like
i mean yeah but like helpful isn't that
what wall street does every day and this
dude was just like in shock you ever
seen that where he was just like back in
this chair he's freaking out
what's the difference of going on cnbc
so yeah you you go on cnbc and you you
pump up your uh stock portfolio i said
you talked to your friend y'all doing
this stuff putting out research and all
that what's the difference
and uh at the end of it he just goes uh
you got a point we got a point i was
like all right touche let's continue
with dinner all right next speaking of
chicken wings no do you remember oh my
god there's a lunch money video back in
2020 when we talked about there was a
short of a shortage of chicken balls
do you remember this no not chicken no
no not like oh god okay hold on
chicken wings i think is what i meant to
say
chicken wings let's go we got like a
minute left wing no we don't yeah oh yes
we do wingstop my uh my trillionaire
energy ad read took too long wingstop is
seeing meaningful deflation the opposite
of inflation in chicken wings so
basically the price of wings last year
hit three dollars and 22 cents a pound
and today it's back at 163 a pound
so there's you know i don't know if you
can call that deflation why uh because
it's not necessarily having to do with
the monetary policy and and all of that
now it is technically the price is going
down so they'll call it deflation
but it's probably much more related to
things like supply chain uh the feed for
the chickens the actual chicken farmers
i guess is what they're called
logistics like all those things end up
playing way more into the price of
chicken uh
and rather than
what's the monetary policy
right
but then during the pandemic i think
there was a lot of demand for chicken do
you remember we went to the store we
couldn't get chicken well i knew i got a
chicken dealer so i was good you do not
have a chicken dealer but i do i have
multiple friends who have chickens the
ceo of they don't kill them yes
how do you think they get eggs that's my
dad the ceo of wingstop said that
they're growing as many birds as they
can right now which means a lot of
supply for the wings out there that that
makes so wingstop is a chicken farmer
the ceo rick ross unhealed wing stops
what i think rick ross google real quick
rick ross i think he owns uh
wingstop yeah we have devolved i'm
pretty sure
oh he does he owns at least 25 wingstop
restaurants which bring in 200 froze
which in
200k each year in sales rose
chicken farmer basically so rick ross is
killing it oh rick ross rick ross
rick ross is an underrated entrepreneur
we're going to get rick ross on the show
actually
we have can you go ahead what's your
question we have ask lunch money time
hashtag asklm on twitter in the comments
wherever you ask us a question i will
find it just use the hashtag asklm
so
okay so somebody asked for individuals
in their 20s to 30s how do you
prioritize between one
wealth building strategy of stacking
bitcoin especially when it's at 30k and
two building assets like investing in
property with huge tax benefits
depreciation cash flow etcetera how do
you what do you do nothing is zero sum
in the world for the most part so
basically some things
why not try to do both okay and
ultimately it comes down to like what
are you optimizing for some people say
hey i want to optimize for taxes okay
well obviously real estate is going to
have advantages over something like
bitcoin okay uh other people say hey i
want to optimize for cash flow okay well
real estate compared to bitcoin real
estate will have advantages over bitcoin
uh but also uh some people say actually
i don't want to have exposure to a
geographic region i don't want to deal
with uh being a landlord i don't want to
deal with uh maintenance i don't want to
deal with having to go select a property
or any of that stuff so maybe bitcoin's
better like there is no one single
answer but i think what ends up
happening is most people say uh i want
to have some level of diversification
once you have some degree of wealth and
uh my guess is that bitcoin and also uh
real estate would fit within uh people's
portfolio so it's not an either or i
think it's an and uh it just comes down
to ultimately what are you trying to
actually optimize for and then it's
waiting in a portfolio should you have
you know 50 bitcoin and 20
uh real estate and the rest in stocks or
cash should you have uh 20 bitcoin 50
real estate like it's hard to save for
one size fits all i think it's more so
what are you optimizing for what's your
risk profile what's your cash flow and
the younger you are the more likely you
can tolerate risk because as you get
older you might want to
lower the risk that is true that's very
that that was pretty good uh yeah that's
pretty good
hey you did you like this video great we
make five of them a day and post them
here on this channel make sure you
subscribe like the video and see you
next time